welcome back so in the last video we
looked at when this inverted pendulum on
a cart is observable okay so we looked
at what C matrices made this pair AC
observable for this full state and also
for just the state x dot theta and theta
dot and so now we're actually going to
develop a calm and filter to estimate
this full state so all four variables
from a single measurement Y and if you
recall we're going to use the
measurement C equals 1 0 0 0 which
corresponds to just measuring the carts
x position the first variable here okay
that was observable so a couple of
things about common filtering or
estimation in general so it's actually
pretty difficult to demonstrate the
Kalman filter for this pendulum in the
up position because that system is
unstable so what happens if I start my
my pendulum in the up position and I
have my cart and I let it go and I'm all
I'm doing is estimating so I'm not
actually doing feedback control I'm just
estimating well very rapidly the
pendulum fall down and it leaves the
region where the linearization was valid
so the linearized model is only valid
near the equilibrium of the pendulums up
and because it's unstable the only way I
can really have a good calm and filter
demonstration for the pendulum in the up
position is to already be stabilizing it
using full state feedback okay so I'm
going to wait to look at the pendulum in
the up position until we're ready to
combine the Kalman filter and the lqr
regulator when we combine those we can
actually look at the system in the
pendulum up condition because our full
state estimate will then be fed back
into an lqr controller it will maintain
the system stability and keep the system
near the fixed point where this model is
valid but for now we're going to look at
this gantry crane configuration where
the pendulum is in the down position and
all we're going to be looking at is the
pendulum essentially moving the cart
moving left and right and the 10
swinging about in the down position okay
so this is stable observable and that's
how I'm going to demonstrate the Kalman
filter okay
and another thing that I think is
important is I'm actually going to
demonstrate the Kalman filter on the
linearized dynamics so I'm really going
to only simulate this linear dynamical
system it is possible to use that and
then apply it to estimate the state in
the full nonlinear system but it's a
little bit easier in MATLAB to show you
everything on the linear system so again
when we combine lqr regulator full state
feedback and the column and filter
estimator when we combine those then
we're going to actually work with the
full nonlinear system okay but for now
we're going to look at the linearize
dynamics about the down position so here
I have my basic code I'm defining the
parameters we're looking at the pendulum
down solution I have my a matrix and my
B matrix okay and now I'm also defining
my C matrix which is my measurement I'm
just going to measure the pendulum start
the cart position and the MATLAB wants
you to give the option of having this
feed through term where the input
directly affects the measurements but in
our case this is just zero there's no
feed through from you directly to Y okay
exodia's Vero's okay so I'm going to run
this code good now to build a common
filter there's a few extra steps that I
need we're going to essentially be
building an Augmented system that
essentially has disturbances and noise
okay so I'm going to draw the system the
following way so I'm going to have my
system that's essentially X dot equals
ax plus bu and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to add in disturbances what
I'm going to call d4 disturbances the
output of the system is going to be Y
but I'm going to add noise to that
measurement
I'm going to add disturbances and noise
to my system and then we're going to
take you the input this might just be
eventually I'm going to close the loop
and use the estimate from my common
filter for full state feedback but for
now let's just say I kick the system
with some UI I give it some force and I
see what happens and then what our
common filter is going to do is
essentially our common filter is going
to take this Y with noise and it's also
going to take this U and our common
filter is going to build an estimate of
the full state X hat and this means
vector X it's this whole state of
position velocity position velocity of
the cart and the pendulum okay so this
is what our common filter is going to do
and so there's a few things I have to
define so first of all VD is a matrix of
disturbance covariances okay and
essentially what I'm going to say is
that these disturbances have essentially
magnitude point 1 times the identity
matrix so they all enter each of these
states equally 0.1 times disturbance 0.1
times to serve as point 1 point 1 if I
wanted to make it so that the theta dot
had a lot bigger disturbances I would
just take that element the 4x4 element
of this matrix and I'd make it a lot
bigger so it has bigger noise covariance
similarly I have to define VN the the
measurement noise noise covariance and
since I have a scalar measurement Y this
is just a scalar covert a scalar
variance for this noise term and I could
make this bigger or smaller and just
like in the linear quadratic regulator
we had the Q and the are matrices that
balance state deviations and control
expenditures these are essentially my
tuning knobs so if I think that my model
uncertainty is high or if I have really
big kicks to the system I'm going to
make the VD no is covariance larger but
if I think I have really nasty big
sensor noise I have really noisy sensors
I'm going to make this V
and larger than VD and the ratio of
those tells me kind of how this comb and
filter is going to balance its model of
the system with the measurements it's
getting from Y okay okay so now what
we're going to do is build this an
Augmented system I'm calling this B F
this is kind of the full or augmented B
matrix so essentially what I'm going to
have is I'm going to add plus I'm going
to say plus V B times my disturbance
plus 0 times noise and down here to my
measurement I'm going to say plus 0
times disturbance plus the N times noise
okay and so essentially I've augmented
my system I'm kind of lumping all of
this stuff together and I'm saying X dot
is ax plus bu plus some disturbance that
disturbance directly enters X dot and my
measurement Y is CX in this case D is
really just 0 so I'm going to actually
put 0 there so my measurement is just CX
it's just the cart position you doesn't
enter disturbance doesn't enter but
there is sensor noise okay and so notice
here in this the B matrix now for my
bigger system where my inputs are u D
and n so u D and n our inputs for my
larger system if I want to draw a box
around this then this is my Augmented
system then the B matrix now is B it
takes it and puts you it takes some
inputs D and it takes it inputs n ok and
similarly my C matrix is just measuring
the cart position but my new D matrix
this feed through term this is
essentially my D term so it's D equals 0
0
vn times my input which is you d and n
ok so I can build this big augmented
state space system that essentially
takes in disturbances inputs and noise
and then just so that I know what the
truth is I'm going to have this other
system full output which essentially has
instead of my restricted measurements y
equals CX I'm going to measure all state
so I have the identity matrix for C so I
measure all of my estates and
essentially what I'm going to do is when
I simulate my system with disturbances
and noise I'm also going to simulate
this truth system as full state output
system so that I can compare my
estimated state with the true state ok
it seems like a lot it actually is kind
of a pain to code this up it would
almost be easier to just build this calm
and filter for a real experiment where I
didn't have to code all this but to show
you in MATLAB I want to actually add
disturbances and noise okay so I'm going
to run this code hope there's no errors
ok good so now I have my system with a
limited measurement and I also have my
true system with the full state output
measurement and I've meant admite to
include disturbances and noise okay so
now the next part is actually pretty
straightforward we're going to actually
build a common filter okay and there's
two ways of doing this I actually like
the second way better but I'll show you
both so in that lab there's a command
called lqe this stands for linear
quadratic estimator okay and it
basically gives you a common filter but
you have to give it a bunch of inputs
you give it the a matrix you give it how
this B matrix this disturbance enters
you give it the measurement matrix C and
then you give it the noise covariances
so here I kind of implicitly assumed
that there's no transfer function from
disturbance to system it's just purely
additive ok
but here you can assume slightly more
general disturbance and noise models and
what you get out I should probably just
call this instead of L let's call it
KF the calming filter game and let's say
okay ought to change everything down
here - okay one more place okay so but
essentially what this outputs is the
calm and filter gain matrix that
essentially the matrix that allows me to
place the eigenvalues of my might
estimator but what I think is a little
bit cooler is that I can actually use
the lqr command remember I said that
observability and controllability are
kind of dual formulations of the same
problem so if I give my lqr command a
transpose and C transpose and I act like
it's a and B and I give it my
disturbance and noise covariances and I
act like it's Q and R what I get out are
my common filter gains just using this
lqr optimization so it's really cool
basically lqr ALK we are solving the
same fundamental equations just in some
kind of a transposed notation so i just
want to show you that you can kind of
hijack the code from the lqr command and
use that to compute this optimal column
filter as long as u transpose things
correctly and this is actually what I
usually do I usually just use the lqr
command for everything cuz I'm really
comfortable with it okay so what have we
done
we had our a matrix our B matrix and our
C matrix those were just from the
linearized equations we're assuming
we're only measuring the cart position
and we want to estimate the full state
in time I have defined some disturbance
and noise covariances so i'm assuming
that my system is being kicked with some
disturbances and there's also sensor
noise and I'm essentially building this
Kuhlman filter gain matrix just like
before
and so what I'm the last thing I have to
do this is actually a dynamical system
this calman filter is its own you know X
hat dot equals ax
Plus be you and so on and so forth and
so I have to define another state space
system just for my calm and filter block
so here the a matrix is a - common
filter Tennessee the B matrix remember
my common filter takes in inputs and I
wish I had reversed the order here but
it takes in and puts you and why so
those go through B and KF the output of
my column and filter I actually want to
measure all of the states that this
column and filter is estimating so I
give it the a 4 by 4 identity that's
going to give me the 4 state output and
I call the filter has no D matrix that
has no feed through term so basically
I'm going to be running my system
outputting this measurement Y and then
I'm going to be feeding that output
measurement Y and my control signal you
into my common filter and the output of
this common filter system is going to be
my full state as measurement X hat ok so
now the last thing we're going to look
at is we're actually going to simulate
the system in the down position and I'm
going to give it nosey measurements and
disturbances and I'm going to kick it
and then we're going to see how well our
common filter estimated all of these
states ok so again this is you know I'm
I'm cooking up an example to show you
all of the pieces in the real world this
would actually be easier if all I had
was measurement Y and you in the real
world for my common filter I'm going to
have a model a B C and I'm going to have
measurements of Y and you okay so that's
all I'm actually going to have in the
real world so let me just draw a little
box around this in the real world I'm
just going to have measurements of U and
Y and I'm going to be building X hat
using my model of the system all of this
stuff is just for my demo okay I'm just
simulating what the system is doing with
disturbances and noise for the demo ok
so I'm going to simulate from time
equals 0.01 to 50 and increments of 0.01
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to build a disturbance signal so I'm
basically going to say that my
disturbance
input is just some big R and and some
big normally distributed random vectors
same thing with my noise my nose is
going to be a big random vector the same
size of time I'm going to say that my
actuation input you I'm going to start
with just zero input and then from
beetee's 100 to 120 I'm going to have a
big positive impulse and from DTS 1500
to 1500 and 20 I'm going to have a big
negative impulse so basically that's
going to be a big positive force in the
X Direction followed by a big negative
force in the X direction so my cart
should lurch forward and then lurch
backward okay then I'm building this big
Augmented input that's going to go into
here and then all I have to do is
simulate the system I'm going to
simulate my system using this else in
command with this big input that has my
actual actuation my disturbance and my
noise so let's just plot that okay so
this whole thing runs and this is kind
of cool what we see is this is time on
the x-axis and the y-axis is my
measurement Y and you'll see this is a
big fuzzy measurement of Y that is
essentially you know the cart is
lurching forward and then lurching
backward okay that's what we thought was
going to happen but there's a ton of
measurement noise on top of this so now
let's actually plot what the true system
is so remember I had that that full
state output model that I'm running in
the background so I'm giving it the same
disturbance but I'm giving it zero noise
so I want to know what the underlying
full state is and then I'm going to plot
that on top and just see what the truth
looks like okay so you can see this red
line here is the true measurement Y the
true cart position without all that
sensor noise from the full state system
and so finally what we're going to do is
we're going to take that measurement Y
and our actuation you
we both know and we're going to feed
that into our common filter system and
we're going to see what the X hat looks
like okay so this is super simple once
we have this column and filter system we
know what the ABC and D matrices are for
this common filter system all I have to
do is simulate it where its inputs are
now U and Y and i'm transposing y here
just so that the the dimensions line up
so i simulate my coleman filter system i
get x why don't I just call this I could
call this X hat I'm just going to call
it X and now I'm also going to plot what
the estimated state is should I not run
my common filter system let's run this
common filter system and my Coleman
filter estimates okay and so now you can
see it might be a little hard to see but
I hope you can see there's this black
dashed line okay so the common filter
measurement why is this super noisy blue
signal but because it has a model of the
underlying dynamics of the system
because we know something about the
system and how big the disturbance is a
noise are and we also know how we're
kicking the system with you
the Coleman filter is able to estimate
this true underlying red signal by this
black dashed dashed curve and so you see
that the black dash curve almost
perfectly lies on top of this red true
underlying car position and so our
Coleman filter is doing a great job of
squashing that noise and really
estimating the true underlying signature
okay so that's very promising but
remember our Coleman filter is not just
supposed to be noise our measurements
why we also want to know what's
happening with all the variables we're
not measuring X dot theta and theta dot
okay so let's finally compare our common
filter so now what we're going to do is
we're going to plot the true x x dot
theta theta dot the pollute the true
signal we're going to plot that in solid
lines and then we're going to plot our
common filter
estimates in - lines this is the last
thing ok and let me move this over a
little so we can see it ok and I'm gonna
so I'm going to walk you through this so
it's a little hard to see because the
curves are so perfectly on top of each
other but each of these four curves is
both the true full States the actual
state of the system without noise and
then the dashed line which perfectly
lies on top is this common filter
estimate except so if i zoom in a little
bit let's hope I can get zoomed in here
you'll actually see that my dashed lines
on these four curves almost perfectly
lie on top of the true solid curves so
what that means is that my common filter
even though the system has disturbances
and very noisy measurements and I'm
actuated it I'm able to very accurately
estimate X X dot the position and
velocity of the cart and theta and theta
dot the position and velocity of the
pendulum just using a single noisy
measurement of the cart position Y okay
so this gives you an idea of how
powerful the column and filter is even
if I only measured one variable I just
measured the cart position I'm able to
back out the position and velocity of
all of my components of my system using
the column filter okay so what we're
going to do next and this is actually
going to be a lot more physical and
intuitive we're going to take the common
filter estimate in X and what we're
going to do finally is we're going to
use that for closed-loop feedback we're
going to say u equals minus K X hat
we're going to use our lqr and we're
going to feed that back as an input to
our system and we're going to actually
simulate the full non-linear inverted
pendulum on a cart so this whole part
here is going to be an actual simulation
of the the real nonlinear system we're
going to use our Coleman filter to
estimate the full state and then we're
going to use that to feed back into our
our lqr regulator okay that's all coming
up thank you